eagle feathers give us that strength and
courage to go on
they've been in our ceremonies
for centuries
and to be able to
have these feathers
in our time of prayer in our time of
need
is really important to us
we're at the national eagle repository
last year we received right at 2700
eagles that were found dead or died for
one reason or another
and we provide loose feathers from
eagles to native americans for their
religious and cultural purposes
they are protected by various laws such
as the bald and gold legal protection
act so
people can't just go picking them up
but this this way it allows native
americans a lawful way to obtain and
possess eagles
the birds that we get have died from
various causes
they often collide with something it
causes them to break a wing and of
course results in death
but usually those injuries are pretty
minor to the feathers so we we could
still use most of the feathers
so we're checking what needs to be
replaced there or what feathers need to
be added in in an effort to try to give
them the equivalent of one whole bird
the role of the natural repository it's
very important it helps us to keep going
with our lives that we know it
it's good to know that you're a part of
something that means so much to a group
of people
and that you're playing a role in
protecting a very treasured resource